why
have we not gotten a ridiculously
awesome
john wick video game yet
man i don't know how to answer that one
you know on the one hand it's the
problem with the ip game
you know um sometimes you get a book
that becomes a shitty movie and a great
tv show
uh an awful mobile game and a great you
know vr experience
sometimes it's crap shoot you're like
how the hell is that great
is that thing but not that other thing
and you know i i the way i describe
anything
is uh you know i was at a screening one
time and
uh just a legendary producer came up to
me he was a fan of
the john wick we were chatting and he
said derek if i knew how to make a good
project i would
and i'm like he's got 150 credits to his
name i get it though
you know i think the other thing too is
you want to start out small
and in video games they encourage you to
go large like to me the best uh
you look at the mcu you wouldn't have
endgame
had it not earned what it was through uh
iron man thor you know the first avenger
all that kind of stuff
and so i think it's a hard balance right
now and the world of gaming is changing
far
faster than anything else you know sure
i also wonder
if there's a way of more games instead
of going for like
spending hundreds of millions of
millions of dollars and creating this
epic
thing that has you know i'm wondering if
it almost could be done
in a smaller scale where you are
creating like a 10 or 20
game that's just really cool that's
more contained and maybe it's instead of
it being a hundred hours it's
five or four well again too is that you
look at the open world of it all
i mean the last game that i spent way
too much time in was
um skyrim you know and that was an
escape it was cathartic it was the only
game i can remember i wandered around
plucking daisies or whatever and going
i'm having a good time you know
and when you look at certain games that
have done
the uh massive world building uh
correctly
it also has the minutia so it'd be a
massive uh
you know kind of endeavor and yet you
know you look at what the hitman games
have done in the past or mdk
25 years ago and things like that and
you're just like
i also missed that you know you're
thrown into it you have a mission go
cool but the best part about john wick
in that universe is
the underlying world it's the
continental it's the high table
and to get there it becomes a more
complex creature you know
sure speaking of the continental
whatever happened with that tv series
what's going on well they're about to
make some uh pretty large announcements
uh in the next couple of weeks
in regards to uh what's gonna happen
there can't say much but it's happening
and uh in regards to everything john
wick you just hope for the best you know
uh completely um
i was told to ask you about your
grandfather and where
john wick comes from nothing like
grandpa man
and in fact grandpa who's still alive
has not seen john wick because the last
r-rated movie he saw was the piano
and uh yeah yeah he saw a lot of harvey
we all got we all saw harvey in that
movie
um and uh you know honestly
for the longest time if you go back to
any other specs you're gonna see
all of the credited uh names on the
posters for
uh uh dirty dozen you know butch cassie
and the sundance kid ronin because they
were on my walls you know
but for my grandpa it just came down to
john wick and i just liked the name
and when we um you know started going
out with it as
the original title scorn piano spent so
much time referring to it as john with
the marketing department's like just
call it john wick it's gonna it's gonna
glean us a great deal of free press
and so it was just kind of like in the
moment and then when it became what it
was
he's just he's tickled man sure
uh of course i have to ask you um as a
huge fan of the franchise
where are you in the writing process of
wick uh four and five i'm actually not
involved in four and five
uh no i mean at a certain stage as the
studio will tell you you've you know
your creation is graduated and you wish
it well
uh i'm still close with chad still close
to dave and you know just
i i don't know what's gonna happen but
uh i'm excited to see you know
and this might be a sore subject but i'm
gonna ask was this your decision was
this a mutual thing
what how are you still executive
producing uh
no it wasn't my decision i mean when you
think of the contractually these things
uh the third one i shared the credit
with any number of people they didn't
have to come back to me and so they
didn't
and so you look at that and you could be
hurt and i would say if i was 20 years
ago i would have been
but seeing what the industry is and how
things go
i just believe that you bless everything
and hope that all the best and to the
players involved who are doing other
things elsewhere
and yet yeah i mean it's personal so i'm
never going to talk [ __ ] about john
wayne
you know i want i want this thing to
survive and thrive yeah i have no
reaction to this i'm sort of stunned
but at the same time it's not like you
didn't land on your feet and are not
involved in like 60 other things
yeah i'm finding a position where i can
make cool [ __ ] with cool people who want
to make cool [ __ ]
i mean that's the playground mentality
and uh
i love it man i'm i'm far more blessed
and i know that
with hard work sometimes these things
come and it's timing and luck and i've
been lucky
with timing and hard work no completely
if you could get the green light and the
financing for any project
tomorrow what would you make and what
honestly one of my dream projects and it
sounds like pandering i just got
and that's helsink and amazon i've been
such a massive fan of that manga anime
for years
that when i was introduced to it a while
ago i was like that's kind of a dream
project
so there's that um but i think
i'm also one of those guys that in my
extra interview with marvel
and any number of other places i don't
have a favorite
i'm the kind of guy that if you build a
sandbox and fill it with sand
and you say do you want to come in here
and make a sand castle i need your help
i'm like [ __ ] yeah
i'm more of a catalyst guy dude so when
you think of what you're passionate
about
uh i don't really have anything that's
100 percent akin to
um the value of self like i need to make
this thing
um because i'm getting to play in the
places that are real
you know um and honestly there are a
couple others i'd love to mention but uh
they're being made by other people sadly
so
i completely understand do you see
yourself directing at some point
or do you feel like that's not your
strong suit it's not my strong suit and
it's not my interest um i saw what dave
and chad
went through to become what they are and
it's just a it's a different
beast it's a different build they're
phenomenal at it
i can't focus on one thing for 18 months
or two years
i love writing i love being alone i love
that the world can [ __ ] off while i type
you know and uh
that just that just has always made me
happy i guess i'm one of the few rare
writers who just
i want to be i want to write i love it